hello
hi there
steve kaufman uh i'm getting ready now
to
to pack and and travel to uh portugal
and spain with my wife our 40th
anniversary trip which i'm really
looking forward to going to work on my
portuguese my hair's a little longer
because i'm looking forward to going to
a portuguese barber shop and hopefully
picking up on the conversation probably
an illusion but who cares
i want to do two quick videos this
morning
this one's going to be about moses
mccormick and open-mindedness
and i'm going to do another one about
reading and literacy and topics related
to that
i want to do an a a video about uh moses
mccormick uh
he also calls himself laoshu which is a
rat in
chinese he's uh
has studied chinese i gather for
i think he at university and and um
but what i want to say about moses is
there are a group of us i would call
them language exhibitionists
uh who will post
videos of themselves speaking foreign
languages
on
youtube
uh moses is one i'm one uh professor
alexander argelias has done so
luca
uh out of italy um
stu j ray and there are many more
very few of them attract
much
traffic so we're not
looking we're not getting we're not you
know we're lucky to get past a thousand
for any one of our videos
so it's a form of exhibitionism but i
think it's it's because we believe
that language learning
is not that big a deal
and i think we all feel that that it's
made into far
too much of an academic difficult
subject with teachers and linguists
falling all over each other coming up
with new terms and all of which takes
away from the enjoyment
of learning another language and if
people did enjoy it more and felt more
confident they'd probably learn better
now where moses stands out if i compare
his achievements to mine or stu j ray or
others
moses like i was born in sweden and at
age five moved to canada
i forgot my swedish but that was a set
then i had english as a second language
i grew up montreal i largely didn't pay
much attention to the french that was
around me till i was well past the age
of 16 but it was there if i wanted it
then i was sent to china to hong kong to
learn chinese and i lived in japan and
so i got a real head start into learning
languages uh i think professor argelia's
lived in korea for a while luca lives in
italy but he travels to spain
stuart j ray i think is also of some
has you know parents of different uh
linguistic backgrounds and so forth and
so on
that's not the case with moses moses
grew up in a unilingual english
environment and just got turned on to
languages you know in his late teens
so
point number one this whole business
about you know you have to be born there
you have to have this you have to have
that i don't believe it i know lots of
people who have learned one language and
who grew up in a in a unilingual
environment
the second thing about moses is moses
doesn't just speak three or four like he
speaks i don't know the number 12 or 15.
now uh there are those who the minute he
posts uh one of these videos if his
accent isn't 100
perfect and if he makes the odd mistake
they're all over him as
criticizing him for not being perfect
you don't have to be perfect that's what
i love about moses he's not afraid to
put up a video of himself but he is very
good he is very good in a lot of
languages languages that are not related
estonian i can't speak for muang or
whatever language that was or swahili i
don't speak those languages but in
russian and chinese and japanese he's
very very good
now obviously if you're going to go
after 10 or 15 languages you're not
going to be perfect in any of them and i
think it's more fun to not be perfect in
15 than to be perfect in one or two you
can't be perfect anyway so but the big
thing about moses and i recommend you
can google moses mccormick language or
something you'll find references to him
you can go and look for him in youtube
uh he did a youtube video recently where
he talked about open-mindedness
and i think that's a very interesting
video to watch
moses has a sort of a folksy rambling
style he's probably less you know
intellectual academic than professor
argelius or i am for that matter
uh
yeah stu j ray is more kind of emotions
and whatever
but uh he has a rambling focus job which
is a very effective style because we
learn from stories and we learn from
examples so he's a story he's an example
and listening to him is very interesting
and his story is
and what he stresses is that the key
is open-mindedness
and he grew up in as he describes it the
pro the what did he call them the
projects
the projects which are these areas in
many towns the united states where
social planners built the sort of
low-cost housing project where
people would presumably i don't know
have cheap housing and
i don't know it's supposed to solve a
perceived
social problem but probably created more
than it solved
the point he makes is that the people
who live in those projects don't have
open minds
so that they are stuck in the culture
and and in some ways and that's not for
me to criticize but it's it's not a very
constructive culture uh those people
there's a lot of violence a lot of drug
abuse uh they they tend not to
have i mean there's a lot of stress and
and conflict and violence and stuff and
not a very satisfactory situation and
that's what they're surrounded with and
that's that then to them that's the norm
and so they don't have a sense of
wanting to pursue pursue something
outside that they don't have an open
mind and he was able
because he was turned on by some friends
he all of a sudden discovered other
things beyond his little
community there and that's what led him
to languages
and i think open-mindedness
it is is the is such an important
element in language learning the thought
that hey there there are other languages
out there that could be of interest
whether i need them for business or not
of interest can enrich my life the
thought that i can learn them and i
thought that i want to communicate with
those people all those are indications
of of uh
an open mind
and it's not just
the moses's background in the projects
where you have people who live in a
little
tribal ghetto where you don't have
open-mindedness we see this everywhere
it can be when i grew up in montreal the
english canadian community very well off
living in montreal didn't bother
learning french they were not
open-minded they were not open or
interested in learning french who needs
it
uh you know we have problems in canada
we have
similar to the projects i mean a lot of
the native communities uh
they're not open-minded they have their
own
sort of social structure which is also
quite destructive uh and we have this in
different
social groups in canada where you have
this sort of generational a welfare
situation now the social workers will
come along and say this is just their
culture their lifestyle it's great but
they aren't really happy there and so
to get out of that
uh
does require a sort of a sense of
open-mindedness it's the same in the uk
which has has the lowest level of
foreign language learning of any country
in europe and they justify it on the
basis of the fact that everybody else
speaks english so why need we bother
again they're not open-minded so i'm not
saying and i've often said that
i don't like to say that people who
don't speak two or three languages are
bad people
but those that
would like to speak more languages
try to be open-minded
learn from moses not the one in the
bible by the way
you know believe you can do it
if you are vaguely interested in
learning a language don't get
discouraged the first time it's a little
difficult
try to find fun ways of doing it have
fun with it that's the other thing about
moses he has fun with it
he's a teacher he teaches people i'm not
sure whether he teaches the language or
he teaches how to learn
but he teaches by example he teaches
because he has fun with it
and you can have fun with it and it can
bring you a lot and so i i just wanted
to to mention this because moses has
these videos which i have i can't say
that i've looked at them all but the
ones that i have looked at i've enjoyed
and i think
he as as a as a storyteller and an
inspiration teacher motivator is
probably more effective than a
a lot of uh
you know
language teachers with credential and
who have studied linguistics and so
forth people need to see and hear and be
inspired by positive examples
and and by examples of people who
not blessed with the best of
circumstances starting out uh have
managed somehow to open their minds up
to language so that's my little uh rant
here on on moses and i encourage you to
go look for him at youtube and i think i
might post a link
on my blog the linguist on language blog
thank you for listening and if you're
listening moses hello there and one day
if i'm in akron or ohio or wherever you
hang out maybe we can have a bowl of
thai noodles together thank you bye for
now